I'd like you all
to ask yourselves a question
which you may never have
asked yourselves before:
What is possible with the human voice?
(Beatboxing)
♪ Ooh baby ♪
♪ baby ♪
♪ baby ♪ (Baby crying)
♪ baby ♪ (Cat meowing)
(Dog barking)
Yeah.
(Applause)
(Boomerang noises)
It was coming straight for me.
I had to. It was, yeah.
As you can probably well imagine,
I was a strange child.
(Laughter)
Because the thing is,
I was constantly trying
to extend my repertoire of noises to be
the very maximum that it could be.
I was constantly experimenting
with these noises.
And I'm still on that mission.
I'm still trying to find every noise
that I can possibly make.
And the thing is, I'm a bit
older and wiser now,
and I know that there's some noises
I'll never be able to make
because I'm hemmed in
by my physical body,
and there's things it can't do.
And there's things that no
one's voice can do.
For example, no one can do
two notes at the same time.
You can do two-tone singing,
which monks can do, which is like...
(Two-tone singing)
But that's cheating.
And it hurts your throat.
So there's things you can't
do, and these limitations
on the human voice have
always really annoyed me,
because beatbox is the best way of getting
musical ideas out of your head
and into the world,
but they're sketches at best,
which is what's annoyed me.
If only, if only there was a way
for these ideas to come out unimpeded
by the restrictions
which my body gives it.
So I've been working with these guys,
and we've made a machine.
We've made a system which is basically
a live production machine,
a real-time music production machine,
and it enables me to, using
nothing but my voice,
create music in real time
as I hear it in my head
unimpeded by any physical restrictions
that my body might place on me.
And I'm going to show you what it can do.
And before I start making noises with it,
and using it to manipulate my voice,
I want to reiterate that everything
that you're about to hear
is being made by my voice.
This system has --
thank you, beautiful assistant --
this system has no sounds in it itself
until I start putting sounds in it,
so there's no prerecorded
samples of any kind.
So once this thing really gets going,
and it really starts to mangle
the audio I'm putting into it,
it becomes not obvious
that it is the human voice,
but it is, so I'm going to take
you through it bit by bit
and start nice and simple.
So the polyphony problem:
I've only got one voice.
How do I get around the problem
of really wanting to have
as many different voices
going on at the same time.
The simplest way to do it
is something like this.
(Beatboxing)
By dancing. It's like this.
(Music)
Thanks.
(Applause)
So that's probably the easiest way.
But if you want to do something
a little bit more immediate,
something that you can't
achieve with live looping,
there's other ways to layer your voice up.
There's things like pitch-shifting,
which are awesome,
and I'm going to show you
now what that sounds like.
So I'm going to start
another beat for you, like this.
(Beatboxing)
There's always got to be a bit
of a dance at the start,
because it's just fun, so
you can clap along if you want.
You don't have to. It's fine.
Check it out.
I'm going to lay down a bass sound now.
(Music)
And now, a rockabilly guitar.
Which is nice. But what if I want
to make, say, a -- (Applause) --
Thanks. What if I want
to make, say, a rock organ?
Is that possible? Yes, it is,
by recording myself like this.
(Organ sound)
And now I have that, I have that recorded.
Assign it to a keyboard.
(Music)
So that's cool.
(Applause)
But what if I wanted to sound
like the whole of Pink Floyd?
Impossible, you say. No.
It is possible, and you
can do it very simply
using this machine. It's really fantastic.
Check it out.
(Music)
So every noise you can
hear there is my voice.
I didn't just trigger something
which sounds like that.
There's no samples.
There's no synthesizers.
That is literally all my voice
being manipulated,
and when you get to that point,
you have to ask, don't you,
what's the point?
Why do this? (Laughter)
Because it's cheaper than hiring
the whole of Pink Floyd,
I suppose, is the easy answer.
But in actual fact,
I haven't made this machine
so that I can emulate
things that already exist.
I've made this so that I can make
any noise that I can imagine.
So with your permission, I'm going to do
some things that are in my mind,
and I hope you enjoy them,
because they're rather unusual,
especially when you're
doing things which are
as unusual as this, it
can be hard to believe
that it is all my voice, you see.
(Voice effects)
(Music)
Like this.
So, loosely defined,
that is what's possible
with the human voice.
Thank you very much, ladies and gentlemen.
(Applause)